making friends as then Prime Minister
David Cameron offered China's president
a taste of British culture
2015 when a desire to do business
trumped security fears
then came the reality
a Crackdown in Hong Kong claims about
human rights abuses and threats against
the island of Taiwan
with policy on China changing the UK
this month revealed some sturdy former
British military Pilots at training the
Chinese Air Force in what it described
as a threat to UK interests
that Sky News has learned the ministry
of Defense itself also helped to train
the Chinese over the years
I've been told by a source that the
ministry of Defense here behind me sent
up to four serving RAF Pilots to Beijing
in September 2016 for around three weeks
to teach what was known as the aviation
English course apparently this was about
helping Chinese Pilots learn about how
to run overseas military deployments
also at least three Chinese officers
have been allowed to go through basic
training at the raf's college in
Lincolnshire one as recently as 2019 and
a number of Chinese Nationals are
thought to have studied here as well the
more senior joint services staff College
in srivenham
a senior conservative MP was shocked I
mean this is just astonishing given the
fact that there's so concerns so many
concerns over the last uh not a couple
of years but indeed the entire decade we
should have woken up to this and we
clearly haven't
it's not just a UK problem
on a visit to a U.S aircraft carrier
operating in European Waters the head of
NATO said all allies must be aware of
China trying to use their knowledge to
gain an advantage
it is absolute an issue that we have
actually on the NATO agenda is how to
not share
expertise knowledge technology with a
country like like China
a spokesperson for the ministry of
Defense said the UK has never provided
fast jet flight training or any other
sensitive training for people's
Liberation Army Air Force pilots
but that still leaves questions about
why concerns weren't raised faster about
former Pilots going off to train the
Chinese debraham Sky News